[Música]
hace algún tiempo vi una película
dirigida por ethan hawk llamada seymour
una introducción y recuerdo
perfectamente unos pocos segundos de la
película cuando el personaje principal
de la historia el pianista compositor y
maestro 6000 bernstein dijo lo más
importante es inspirar una respuesta
emocional en todos los aspectos de la
vida él estaba diciendo esto a sus
alumnos de piano y de inmediato descubrí
que esto era absolutamente cierto no
solo al enseñar sino como decía en todos
los aspectos de la vida de hecho hay
innumerables trabajos de investigación y
experiencias prácticas que demuestran
que los estudiantes mejoran su
aprendizaje cuando están involucrados
emocionalmente en el proceso les cuento
esto porque la historia que les les
relataré me emociona mucho y realmente
espero que también lo haga con ustedes
desde hace 38 años que soy profesor aquí
en esta facultad y esta es una historia
de enseñanza y aprendizaje pero es una
historia en la que no soy yo el que
enseña sino el que aprendió aprendí una
de las lecciones más importantes de toda
mi vida y el que me la enseñó fue mi
hijo así que permítanme comenzar esta
historia diciéndoles que tengo 59 años
he estado felizmente casado con mi
querida esposa susy desde hace más de 30
años y que tenemos dos maravillosos dos
maravillosos hijos jessica de 28 años y
damián de 25 nací en una familia judía
de clase media en la que viví una vida
relativamente normal en la que ciertas
cosas se establecieron como reglas de
facto se suponía que debía casarnos con
una mujer judía y tener una familia
judía con hijos que eventualmente
continuarían esa tradición
en ese escenario supuestamente ideal no
había lugar para dudas o conceptos
erróneos un hombre debía casarse con una
mujer y una mujer debía casarse con un
hombre sin dudas sin conflictos
cualquier otra posibilidad debería ser
eliminada de nuestras vidas porque era
simplemente impensable imposible de
aceptar además esto era algo que
nosotros nunca habíamos discutido en
nuestra familia para que en nuestro
mundo ideal este tipo de cosas no
existen pero esto era cierto no sólo
para mi familia sino también en la
escuela donde cualquier tipo de señal de
ternura en un niño sería castigada no
sólo por sus compañeros sino también por
los maestros y la misma situación en los
programas de televisión en los deportes
y donde quiera que vayan un hombre debe
ser un macho y cualquier signo de
debilidad o flojedad merecería recibir
el apelativo de [ __ ] dígame la verdad
no le suena a esto especialmente si son
no son muy jóvenes por lo tanto era
normal para mí creer que ésta era la
única verdad
las otras posibilidades estaban
equivocadas un error por desgracia hemos
vivido durante siglos en un mundo de
falsas certezas en un mundo regido por
normas religiosas graves e inmutables
permítanme citar algunos párrafos de la
biblia cuando el señor termino de
hablarle a moisés en el monte sinaí le
dio las dos tablas de la ley del pacto
las tablas de piedra grabadas con el
dedo de dios la ley fue escrita en
piedra por el dedo de dios como
atrevernos a modificarla a ir en contra
de lo que se estableció previamente y
este es otro párrafo bíblico si alguien
se acuesta con otro hombre como se hace
con una mujer abominación hicieron ambos
han de ser muertos sobre ellos caerá su
sangre puedo continuar con otros
ejemplos pero creo que alcanza para
entender a qué me refiero nuestros
padres sus padres y todos nuestros
antepasados fueron educados bajo estas
leyes y nosotros recibimos esta
educación y no había posibilidad de
pensar de una manera diferente y si
alguien se atrevía a sentirse diferente
mejor que oculte sus sentimientos para
no ser visto como un extraño como
alguien que está fuera de este mundo
perfecto
por lo tanto si nos equivocamos no fue
culpa de nuestros padres ni de nuestros
abuelos fue culpa de la herencia humana
pero no digo esto como una especie de
excusa realmente creo que somos absoluta
y únicamente responsables de nuestros
propios actos pero déjenme continuar con
mi historia durante mis primeros 45 años
más o menos vivir bajo esas falsas
certezas y nunca imaginé cuando allí no
pudo haber sido expresar algunas bromas
o comentarios sin ninguna mala intención
pero luego sucedió que mi hijo mi propio
llamado hijo habló conmigo sobre sus
sentimientos que le gustan los hombres
que es gay en ese momento me enfrenté
con todas mis creencias anteriores con
toda mi historia personal de vida era mi
hijo el que me decía esto y yo lo amo y
quiero que él tenga la vida más feliz
posible y toda mi vida cambió en ese
momento por supuesto yo lo apoyé le dio
un abrazo y le dije que su felicidad era
lo más importante para mí pero al mismo
tiempo descubrir lo fuerte que debió
haber sido él para transitar todos estos
años desde que descubrió sus verdaderos
sentimientos hasta que finalmente pudo
hacer quien realmente es qué tan fuerte
debió haber sido él para no enfrentar a
aquellos que como yo se referían sin
querer de manera grosera acerca de
personas homosexuales qué triste y
culpable me sentí en ese momento por los
comentarios anteriores que podría haber
dicho sin mala intención pero con mucha
ignorancia
y fue en ese momento cuando me di cuenta
que mi hijo me estaba enseñando una
lección una de las más importantes de
toda mi vida y esa elección fue que no
tenemos derecho a hacer que alguien más
sienta pena por amar a quien él o ella
quiere amar vivimos en un mundo donde el
odio está en todos lados donde los
políticos dicen cosas en las que no
crean un mundo en el que las personas
están más preocupadas por su aspecto que
por cómo tratan o sienten el uno por el
otro
necesitamos más amor necesitamos más
sinceridad necesitamos lo que la
comunidad deje de cv no se está
mostrando el orgullo de ser lo que somos
la honestidad de vivir de la manera que
queremos el coraje para luchar contra la
injusticia el amor contra viento y marea
quizás en este momento se estén
preguntando cómo lidiar con este tema y
permítanme decirles que no necesitamos
lidiar con este tema de la misma manera
que no tenemos que lidiar con lo que
otras personas hacen o piensan o dicen
es su derecho a ser o pensar o decir lo
que quieran
a lo único que le tenemos que hacer
frente es a nuestros propios prejuicios
lo único de los que nos tenemos que
cuidar es de no hacer que alguien más
sienta pena por ser lo que es y esto es
particularmente cierto en nuestras aulas
para los que somos maestros porque no
sólo enseñamos nuestra disciplina sino
también actitudes y valores
también para los que son estudiantes
tratando a sus compañeros con respeto y
sin prejuicios y si hay alguien en este
salón que cree que vive de una manera
contraria a sus sentimientos que tiene
que ocultar quién realmente es a causa
de lo que piensan los demás permítanme
sugerirles que no lo hagan más la vida
es una sola y merecemos vivirla a
nuestra manera y con nuestras propias
verdades entonces seamos parte del
debate participemos activamente en la
defensa de los derechos individuales de
las personas
enseñémosles a las personas con las que
convivimos a no hacer comentarios
hirientes sobre nadie más y aún más
importante que eso aprendamos a pedir
disculpas si involuntariamente decimos
algo hiriente sobre otra persona espero
que como dijo el pianista seymour
bernstein con estas palabras ella podría
inspirar una respuesta emocional en
todos ustedes muchas gracias
i
en un mundo